this episode of star talk is brought to
you by curiosity stream so tonight we're
going to talk about the exploration of
the universe and the search for life in
that exploration and what impact they
might that might have on us
philosophically culturally religiously
on our artwork and all that we are and
define ourselves to be as humans and
let's bring out oh yes you like that
okay
so let's bring out one of my scientific
gets a colleague and a friend in fact a
hometown native give a very warm welcome
to dr. Carolyn Porco
[Applause]
Carolyn Parker's at hometown native
she's a planetary scientist she was head
of the imaging science team of the
Cassini mission to Saturn if you saw any
image of Saturn in the last 15 years she
did it
she and the team
I call her Madame Saturn thank you thank
you I love that um it is my great
pleasure to bring out comedian wonderful
comedian from wet hot American summer
and many many other things ladies and
gentlemen here's a new show called
debate Wars out on sea so ladies and
gentlemen Michael Ian Black
[Applause]
you know what I'm gonna go around want
me to go around
[Applause]
and from Saturday Night Live and
trainwreck ladies and gentlemen Vanessa
Bayer
[Applause]
and rounding this out we can't do this
if we're going to talk about art we need
an artist so we're gonna talk about the
impact of science on our lives we need
somebody who sits at that intersection
give a very warm welcome to musician and
artist Sean Ono Lennon
[Applause]
oh right so let's just get some basic
science on the table Carolyn we went to
Saturn
we didn't he did it in an awesome way we
went it we entered orbit back in 2004
for and it's been going gangbusters
since then yes why go to Saturn oh wow
sorry okay be a little more specific
what were you after what do we not know
about Saturn that you found out well let
me back up in a start I'm at the
beginning with the Voyager mission okay
the Voyager mission we toured the outer
solar system in the 1980s and we had two
spacecraft encounter Saturn in 1980 and
1981 and that was really the first time
we ever got a glimpse of what the
Saturnian system offered so we got to
see the surfaces of the satellites we
got to see the Rings in some detail and
as these things often happen you know it
was just a wonderful exploration and
journey of discovery and all those
accolades you've heard but they really
leave us with other questions that we
like to answer and so as soon as the
Voyager mission was over everybody was
deep into planning the next mission to
return to Saturn because that was
considered the system the planetary
system it is the planetary system that
is the most phenomenologically rich so
it has Titan that means it's the most
beautiful it's also the most beautiful I
was in the privileged position of being
responsible for the images that we
returned so I just very much wanted to
make them beautiful yeah just give give
it up yeah
[Applause]
so you couldn't just send Cassini there
you needed some gravitational help last
I remembered we got it launch it from
Earth and you don't have enough energy
enough propulsion to get it there so you
steal orbital energy from what well this
is a maneuver that was found before
going to Voyager but if you fly a
spacecraft by a planet let's say that is
already moving then depending on how you
fly the spacecraft by the planet you can
actually take a little bit of momentum
from that body but because the planet so
big and the spacecraft is so small you
really give a big kick to the spacecraft
so in order to get to Saturn we actually
flew around the inner solar system for
two years kind of parked it there
building up speed we flew by Venus twice
the earth once and it never went back in
time you did a double slingshot around
Venus not around we just flew by it by
its slingshot Venus and you also
slingshot earth yes we did okay now did
we just get you just got lucky that you
ended up on Saturday you would figured
all this out look I tell you if they had
left me in charge of the navigation we
would ended up in Uranus so they do have
a group of people
they haven't they have a group I'd like
well anyway terrible I have terrible
sense of direction
she just reference your I know yeah okay
but but so so this is like a three
cushion pool shot off of three planets
any more planets on the way no no then
we went by Jupiter and we went by
Jupiter incidentally on the eve of the
year 2001 which I thought was like so
incredibly bitching bitching 1963 was
the venue center Camaro so all right so
you slingshot Jupiter and now you got
enough energy to get to Saturn yeah just
twice again as far away as Jupiter is
yes I'm it's another three years to do
it so it took us seven years in total to
cross the solar system alright cool and
then it gets pulled into orbit and
you've got rings you've got magnetic
fields you've got all manner of things
going on there you want my favorite I've
two favorites one you found lightning on
Saturn we did yes we captured lightning
on Saturn and it's raining like what's
going on well it's doing essentially
what lightning does here it's company by
thunder and rain and so on these are big
convective storms that produce your
brain on Saturn yeah we do is it water
water or some other liquid
what this is in the water clouds yeah
the water clock but you have other
clouds and if they rained it wouldn't be
rain water it'd be like rain ammonia or
something it could be rain ammonia I
guess we're that's too deep for us to
know much about what we knew about the
water clouds
okay Debbie we ammonia rain but
everything would be clear all rights all
right we got that and then what freaked
me out to this day was this hexagon in
Saturn's with South Pole with it north
North Pole a hexagon no we know
there are no hexagons in the universe
how did you what is that okay so this is
I'm glad you brought this up because
every time we released something about
the hexagon on our website Cyclops org
or hits went through the roof you know
because I think people think this has
something to do with crystal energy and
what it what's of you know yes aren't
like a hexagon is a common crystal
cross-sectional shape yeah but it's the
straight sides in an atmosphere that
really blew people away so we've
explained over and over and over again
that this is just a continuous wave with
just six waves in it jet stream that
encircle Saturn it's nothing more than
that it's very similar to what we have
here on the earth except on the earth
it's very discontinuous because the
system that jet stream is traveling over
the oceans and Hillandale and so on and
friction just wears it down but on
Saturn there is no friction so it just
is continuous so is it was just so it's
like in my mind it's like this I'm like
picturing the shape that you learn about
like when you learn about octagon
hexagon is six-sided so right I knew
that so and then there's and then
there's there's water it's jet streams
well it's a jaqen it's a jet stream of
air on Saturn and at that level I don't
know it's probably hydrogen mostly
hydrogen but it's it's it's just a jet
stream its just very regular because
there's nothing to disturb it that's and
it's at the bottom no it's in the top or
the atmosphere it's at the pole got it
okay so so so so Carolyn I just want to
comment that you're all calm and casual
or it's just the hexagon degree which is
Wayne don't tell me you didn't freak out
when you first saw the hexagon well we
first saw the hexagon with Voyager and I
was very free Keable when I was young
but you know by the time
that's linen if you get your freak on
you know so uh so it's just easy in
retrospect to say how to explain what
you're looking at but it seems to me
that's a pretty impressive thing to
discover on a planet that's all and you
said well Earth has it too it's just not
a hexagon but then we don't have it well
ok so that's why we went you asked why
do we want to discover all those things
they're the same and are different about
our planet because ultimately we want to
learn about process and process the more
we learn about process about planets the
better custodians of our own planet we
can be so that's what planetary
exploration is all about it so aside
from having aside from having a really
bitchin time all right so I tell me
about the any questions you thought you
would have answered but didn't get
answered
oh well we still don't know exactly what
the mass of Saturn's rings are and it's
important if you're interested in
figuring out how old they are where they
came from and that whole process so in
fact that's what the end of the Cassini
mission is aiming to do eventually to
measure the mass of Saturn
there's they're really skinny they are
really skinny they're only about thirty
feet thick yet they extend for 280,000
kilometers which is about one
light-second it would take light the
fastest thing we know one second to
travel across the Rings they would fit
in nicely between the earth and the moon
and we've discovered so many things in
there just let me know when we can start
them now
[Laughter]
I'm gonna explain this in layman's terms
for the audience
Saturn's really big really big why are
the Rings
so thin in comparison you really want to
know the answer to this no I just asked
I felt like I should say something but
just to be clear they are so thin when
Saturn is edged on when their edge on to
us they disappear entirely well not
really
let me try that again they're so thick
they disappeared then are they
they disappear mostly Muslim [ __ ] but
they but you wanted to know okay it's a
real simple physics 101 explanation I
didn't get that far
they consist of lots and lots and lots
of icy particles chunks of ice that are
like that tiny all the way to the size
of small apartment buildings and when
they collide which they did in the early
days after they formed and we think they
formed by two satellites colliding with
one another something like that this
creates a cloud of debris and these
particles are in very wild and crazy
orbits and when they collide they lose
energy but they conserve angular
momentum this is a process that even has
produced the disks of galaxies that we
know they collect the spiral galaxies
which are very thin also compared to
their horizontal dimensions so does that
mean that earth will eventually have a
ring of space junk and debris hahaha
well it would have to it could if we
left enough junk up there so that they
collided that actually would happen yeah
and as in Saturn just like a mini solar
system I mean in terms of the way this
our solar system formed and can't you
make that analogous the way the discs
are yes the moon count if you want to
analogize into planets what's the moon
count for Saturn right now I've lost
track it's as over 60 s over 60 we don't
know how many moons I'm sorry I don't
not yet
allow me to defend this bit of ignorance
girl can't know you reach a point where
the number of something is not as
important as what the thing actually is
good for you sounds like a complex so so
when people were taught that there were
nine planets in the solar system and
then Pluto got kicked out people cried
foul because they thought science was
about the number and they got Jack to do
with the number
if it didn't they just find a ninth
planet anyway and is that why science
has since stopped measuring things but
hasn't cleared up and replaced by some
they detected a wobble that might mean
there's another planet out there that we
didn't know about way verify in the
Kuiper I just find that so hard to
understand that we could have had a
planet in our own solar system that we
haven't seen it you know this episode is
brought to you by curiosity stream a
subscription streaming service made for
those of you who have no shame in your
nerd game with over 2500 DQ memories and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals get unlimited access
starting at just $2.99 a month and for
our audience the first 31 days are
completely free if you sign up at
curiosity stream comm slash Startalk and
use promo code Startalk make sure you
check out Stephen Hawking's favorite
places renowned physicist Stephen
Hawking takes a flight of epic
proportions to visit his favorite places
in the universe a three part curiosity
stream original series and an Emmy
winner go to curiosity stream comm slash
star talk for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries at nonfiction
series and for our listeners and a promo
code Startalk when prompted during the
signup process and your membership is
completely free for the first 31 days
all right so so among the 60 moon 60
plus means there couple of moves that
rise up in their significance to those
in search for life or interesting things
going on on move so what what can tell
us about yes so these are the two best
moves there are okay the first one is
tightened it's about 50% larger than our
own moon
it has a thick atmosphere of molecular
nitrogen it has a thermal structure
that's like our own Earth's here and so
it's in some sense it's a mini earth
except that it does not have oxygen in
it free oxygen and its atmosphere and it
has organic materials in its atmosphere
and those organic materials we suspected
would be found on the surface in liquid
form and we didn't find them at first
then we didn't find them after a year or
two and then finally we found that they
went to the polls the liquids on Titan
are liquid hydrocarbons that are ponded
at the poles and that's a word pundit
pandu that's cool I like someone get
riseth on that's good I like it doesn't
that we made it a word here now if it
wasn't previously okay I think it was a
word so so so liquid hard like methane
methane and ethane yes so things like
methane is the gas that comes out of
your stove typically if you live in a
city so that's flammable that's very far
most good question about moons just for
the audience I do know the answer the
difference between like a moon and a
planet is that the moon orbits around
yes and they're generally smaller
generally okay there's some moons that
are bigger than the planets no I don't
really think so there's only one you
said generally that I got because I was
just covering my body
so Eugene if the moon were bigger than
the planet the planet would be the moon
and the moon would be the planet yeah
yeah that's what I figured until he said
generally they're made of like the same
kind of cool stuff right but not the
same stuff right well they're all
different but do moons have elements in
common that you know all share certain
elements that they're all made by
elements I mean like all right let me
help you oh yeah sure help them out so
in the Saturn system for example the
moons are largely made of water ice
because it's so cold out there that
water becomes you know it's like a rock
you get to Uranus and then you get to
Neptune which are much farther out you
have moons that actually have methane on
there sir solid methane so it just solid
methane yeah so you pull the gas down
you liquefy it cool it some more then
you get a solid and that's laying around
the moons of Uranus and Neptune yeah is
also liquid nitrogen I mean you know
most of our atmosphere I mean a solid
nitrogen most of our atmospheres is
molecular gaseous nitrogen but by the
time you get to Neptune Neptune we've
got nitrogen on the surface it on on
Pluto you heard a lot about nitrogen
flowing on the surface of Pluto yeah
yeah you used to hear about it
but to Vanessa's point hey let's leave
time to get to my favorite moon Vanessa
yeah just to be clear yes the fact that
the moon is comprised of ingredients
that are essentially identical to
Earth's crust is one of the factors that
led us to suggest that the moon was
formed by a sideswipe of a planetesimal
in the early solar system scattering
countless tons of Earth's crust into a
ring of debris around Earth that would
later coalesce and form what today we
call the moon hallelujah but didn't they
just study the moon rocks that they've
gotten in 1969 and they just realized
that the collision that created the moon
was not a graze it was actually
something a lot more impactful I just
reads up on everything I got watch out
for you yeah yeah we gotta watch out so
the question is how deep did it actually
graze actually and it could not have
gone too deep because if you get too
deep in Earth on earth when Earth was
molten in its early days the heavy stuff
fell to the middle the lighter stuff
floated to the top so nearly all of
Earth's iron and platinum and iridium
and gold is in our core and if you
psyched if you sideswiped enough to
reach the core you would scatter the
heavy elements into what would become
the moon and the moon would have an
appreciable amount of heavy elements it
doesn't it just doesn't for something
that size it should have a whole iron
core and it got nope it's got nothing no
so I shouldn't go to the moon to get any
platinum well now I need a new thing to
do in February
so I just want to be clear but he has a
completely sensible question and that
question when applied to the earth-moon
system led to an entire new
understanding of the formation of the
moment just so which planet is a
candidate to the sideswiped us which
right which planet is a candidate to we
think it may be completely destroyed oh
just it's gone is that what the asteroid
belt is now or something
asteroid belt yeah it's got a lot of
debris but if you add it all up it
doesn't come to much okay it comes about
like 5% of the mass of the moon right
yeah it's very it's fair enough I
wouldn't had to be a planet sized thing
and it's likely that this the projectile
broke up and is now part of the moon
can I offer an alternate hypothesis yeah
space right space for a laser gun gamma
ray gamma ray yeah laser gun it could
have been what level beaten are you I
can't remember can't divulge it alright
so yeah Titan but if we gonna look for
life which inspires so much of our
invested emotion and energy in space
exploration Titan doesn't sound like the
place we would find life as we know it
yeah it would be very difficult very
fine
the killer wouldn't look like a goat or
it would be like super not a go yeah
yeah not a go right so can you ask him
about it is that what you were asking we
don't done so what else is tantalizing
okay so life so to me the most
provocative and most thrilling result we
found is that this little moon called
Enceladus which is no bigger across than
England I mean it's very small has
geysers she was shooting out that extend
hundreds of miles above the surface in
fact they if you follow some of them
they go tens of thousands of kilometers
away from Enceladus and they form the
e-ring but these geysers we now know
after being there but just like the
Saturn's rings have been lettered yeah
one of which is called the here a one of
which is called the okay the Pentagon
has an earring Oh does it I've got a
phone that has a ring how many rings
dissenter don't ask those questions let
me finish one thought at a time tell me
about it so you know you know we don't
count things anymore right
one last County so eerie I mean
Enceladus
so these geysers we know come through
four major fractures at the South Pole
which is a really unique interesting
terrain structures in the ice in the ice
in the ice shell sorry there's an ice
shell that exists lies on top of a
global ocean of salty liquid water that
is suffused with organic materials and
we know that because after being there
awhile we we figured all this out and
then later on in the mission we actually
send the spacecraft through the plume to
pick up material and analyze its
composition so like we got this down pat
you have that much remote control over
what next orbit your spacecraft took you
know you know how you operate drones
yeah wait so when you say organic
material what do you mean like what
constitutes
did we find space Cael
close to it close enough but a simple
stuff like you know things compounds
that contain carbon and hydrogen and
oxygen and nitrogen and things like that
those are the basic bye what I'm kidding
sorry the basic bio elements that you
and I are made out of yeah you know plus
a lot more but especially you
[Laughter]
okay so Carolyn I I'm less impressed
that there are organic materials there
because these you just listed some of
the most common kinds of atoms in the
universe the question is is in sodus in
a kind of state where we can think of it
containing life as we know it yes
because it has an ocean and why is it
it's outside the Goldilocks zone have
subsurface ocean okay I see where you're
going with this it as a subsurface ocean
and we found through whatever it's been
now nearly 60 years of exploring planets
both from ground-based observations
using telescopes and our spacecraft that
there are several moons in our solar
system that have subsurface oceans and
so they're liquid ocean liquid walked
and had to be melting them it's not the
Sun it's not every ocean a subsurface
not not the Pacific but it isn't it sub
no sub means it's under the ground think
of it that way except the ground on
Enceladus is ice the top of it the
started cylinder on this earth okay
buddy
because I was like what do you think you
know really it's like it's like when you
have a chocolate cake the frosting is on
top the cake is sub cake
and then and then sometimes there's a
layer of frosting yes okay do we have
that we are
but just to be clear Vanessa uh until
recently the North the North Pole Ocean
is an ocean under a layer of ice so your
question was not out of nowhere I mean
you can't have oceans on earth under
layers of ice yeah usually able to used
to be able to yeah kid can I ask a dumb
question you referred to this South Pole
how do we gauge north and south on a
moon in space the way it's spinning no
we know great Rinna hold out your right
hand okay like this curl your fingers if
your fingers curl in the direction of
the rotating object your thumb points to
the North Pole so if it's spinning like
this and we know that these moons are
spinning we've been there a long time we
got that down if it's spinning like this
then that's what he means the North Way
but Venus rotates the other way so what
would the north be reversed on Venus
like so if anything that seems to rotate
this way you take a hand do that and
then the North Pole would be down
okay so Venus is north pole is south of
everyone else's right hand rule to
establish what is north sure yeah I got
that yeah so go on so okay let me finish
finish this story so that's why we could
all agree what is north no matter what
object we're looking at well that guy
doesn't agree over there all right so
we're where you go so liquid water
organic compounds that we know come from
the ocean and it's being heated by tidal
flexure okay so it's in a resonance
which makes its orbit eccentric
sometimes as far away from Saturn
sometimes it's close and that means that
the tidal forcing varies and that's how
you get tidal energy injected into one
of these bodies there's enough of it to
keep the ocean stable and so this is
what nASA has been saying for decades
now would be the formal requirements
that
we would want to know exist in on a body
so that we'd mount the next kind of wave
of exploration and go there but in
particularly to look for life and so
that's where we are with Enceladus so
the the Goldilocks zone that is so
celebrated can exist in other ways
outside of the traditional two
Goldilocks zone there really is no
Goldilocks zone as it pertains to
distance from the Sun but there is a
Goldilocks zone in the sense that well
there is not know it just because all
you need is something that sorts of
people well they're not it's the Sun
yeah but you ultimately need something
like tidal energy how are the oceans
what how warm are those oceans well we
don't really know but they have to be at
least you know the the temperature of
liquid water like zero degrees Celsius
or 32 degrees and they got it they got a
pack some punch
if you blow in geyser is a hundred
hundred kilometers in the sky that's not
hard to understand because the weight of
the overlying ice shell forces the water
up the cracks and then there's also
volatile materials like we've seen in
Japan they have special toilets that do
that
we want to go question about okay so if
you're looking for life on that moon has
anyone ever thought maybe this is very
irresponsible but has anyone ever
thought like well what if we just threw
a bunch of bugs in there what you want
to do that well just to see if they
could like live and create like an
animal where iam I mean we're not but
wouldn't it be so cool and then you come
back five years later and they've all
grown up and we put this is just an idea
we put enough trout that when we get
there again we is that really so bad
okay so so nASA has an entire office
called planetary protection yeah they do
and their goal is to preserve planets
this would include moons that may have
life from contamination of life from
Earth and to preserve life on Earth from
any bugs that might accidentally be
brought back from our planetary mission
it's called forward and backwards
forward and backwards contamination
those planets have that with us so why
are we like they don't have an agreement
so until we know that a planet is
completely sterile which that we want to
be really careful this episode is
brought to you by curiosity stream make
sure you check out Stephen Hawking's
favorite places renowned physicist
Stephen Hawking takes a flight of epic
proportions to visit his favorite places
in the universe a three-part curiosity
stream original series and an Emmy
winner go to curiosity stream comm slash
star talk for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and nonfiction
series and for our listeners and a promo
code Startalk when prompted during the
signup process and your membership is
completely free for the first 31 days
so you are also part of the Voyager team
which had messages for aliens that might
find this spacecraft is on you it has
escaped our solar system and so this
movement to try to contact
extraterrestrial life be it microbial or
what we might call intelligent it's been
going on for a while but some people
might ask since that Voyager record a
Voyager record contained data that would
allow aliens to triangulate back to find
out what planet in the galaxy this was
launched from yes this is basically our
return address right do you give
strangers your email address other
humans that have DNA in common with you
you do I do it's on my website
Cyclops org yeah yeah okay again yeah
Vanessa do you know I'm just saying I'm
just I'm curious about the the it's not
the ethics of it but the the sensibility
of alerting and we all know what aliens
will do when they find humans we've seen
this many times played out
so so this is really tell this to Carl
Sagan at the time that he put the and he
and Ann Druyan put the record on the
spaceship no I did not
okay no I did not everyone was very
hopeful everything will be peace
everyone thought it was well you know
it's on a spacecraft that you know is
fast to us but it's going pretty slow
it's not gonna get too far you know I
mean it's you know but there are there
are people myself included wanted to
send messages into the galaxy encoded on
transmissions coming from the most
powerful radio dishes we have here on
the earth the arecibo telescope is one
Frank Drake famous astronomer
radio astronomer started this in 1974 he
relayed a message to m31 as a globular
cluster in our galaxy actually it was a
demonstration of the power of the
transmitter on that telescope which they
had just brought online and he and his
creativity and his just exuberance and
wondering about life elsewhere
constructed this message that was
encoded on the signals and they sent it
into space very celebrated thing and I
wanted to do it again except do it
better and there's even a website where
I describe this but suddenly there is a
foot this movement of people who think
that this is a terribly dangerous thing
it is Stephen Hawking
yeah it does it includes Elon Musk yes
and they think that we are endangering
the planet to let aliens know where we
are we endanger ourselves when one
civilization encounters another in the
history of life on Earth right so the
extrapolation is you know so a much more
powerful advanced civilization
encounters us it's going to be like
humans encountering flies and they'll
just want to like squish us and die you
know
can I say we're already doing it that's
my argument that's the counter-argument
what is the counter I have yet to hear
counterpart and and the counter-argument
is not due to me that people have been
saying this for a long time now but the
idea is that any civilization that is
advanced enough to come knocking on our
doorstep has already filtered out I mean
if you've got that far it has to be
benign because if it wasn't benign it
would have destroyed itself so yeah can
I say what my can I say what my feeling
is no I just feel like even if this
advanced civilization is so much more
advanced that we're like ants relative
to these aliens then whatever they want
even if it is enslaving me I kind of
feel like that would be the right thing
to do anyway you know I mean if they're
so smart if they think that you know I
should be basically you know the coffee
boy or something this is a guy who are
helpful with authority figures they know
everything so they must know what's
right for us then and it might be
squashing us they're lucky tonight is
part five you're making a pro-slavery
argument
[Applause]
but I believe you think needs coffee
coffee they would come here do you think
they'd stay awake on those long
interstellar flights
it's definitely Starbucks okay wait wait
so you were saying then a sufficiently
intelligent civil ensign otherwise with
that technology and power if they were
evil they'd be evil to each other and
destroy one another as we were on the
brink of a few decades ago possibly even
decades to come and so fine and now
you're gonna say they're so smart they
have our best interest in mind
well they'll have they'll know what's
right better than we'll know what's
right I think that they'd be so evolved
literally evolved then they will have
they will appreciate life because they
will have studied they probably know
already what's going on inside what what
I was gonna ask is why don't what have
we said to them and doesn't it also
matter like what we say like if we're
like Oh everyone's nice here you guys
should stop by or if we're like we're
like we really are coordinates like
where we are you know we're built on DNA
I mean this is what we look is it ever
like a pea recipe or anything good like
they could try this thing me like this
is fun I wonder if they have more of
that
they come with a l1 paia plus if they
show up and there's some appendage
sticking out maybe that's not what you
should shake because you don't know
alien Anatomy for example I'd love to
pull on an alien penis that's a sign of
friendship
how do we give them our coordinates and
stuff just do we just think that they
know our well you know you have to make
certain assumption it's actually a very
an all seriousness this is a very
interesting fascinating intellectual
exercise to go through to figure out how
you would communicate with yeah an alien
alien organism you have to assume
they're not gonna speak English they're
not gonna speak there was no some french
recap if an alien landed in my backyard
and things Gerard Depardieu was an angel
from another world so you'd have to
assume that they know the geography of
the galaxy and that they know about
electromagnetic radiation and all its
properties and they know physics and
maybe they have math to something like
it because they got here I mean they had
to get here from you know yeah
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of light-years away
yeah right yeah they didn't just fold
space on a lucky guess they probably I
wonder if they know about wormholes you
know like the whole contact yeah why
wouldn't they
I'll give wormholes I want where all so
if if they know what the best we asked
for a wormhole cuz tell them that you
want to work home I'll let them know
cuz I think you're next to make contact
there so
I actually left my cell phone upstairs
all right so so Carolyn you are hopeful
and I'm delighted to hear that you're
more hopeful than I am because there's a
look at how see how tribal we are human
to human
and somehow you're thinking we wouldn't
be human tribal against aliens or
vice-versa but there's no guarantee that
we're gonna make it we may be one of
these failed civilizations if we don't
get our act together we're we we haven't
we haven't passed we haven't passed the
test yet so we may we may just go by way
of all those civilizations that just
destroyed themselves and we're not going
to get to participate in the Nirvana
that awaits all the peaceful well
hopefully that'll be a future generation
what gets me is I we they're all these
outerspace treaties that the UN comes up
with and peaceful use of outer space and
and friendship in outer space and I'm
thinking I have very little confidence
in that because why would you think that
on earth we'd like killing each other
but in space oh that's a place to be
friends
you don't think Isis would be super nice
on the moon
I am not nice I'm not convinced that we
will treat each other better in space
than we do on earth until we know how to
treat each other better on earth all
right it's time to wrap up all this talk
about death and AI when we come back
we're going to take your questions on
everything cosmic about the future of
the human race on earth or in space on
Startalk
[Applause]
let's go straight on in if you come from
someplace other than New York I would
welcome to know your point of origin sir
go ahead what's your question come from
ten blocks away sir
ten blocks away what country is that is
that so
so my questions Elon Musk has been doing
a lot of stuff in SpaceX on launching
stuff into space but it seems like his
underlying motive is really to colonize
Mars to some extent and you just wanted
to get kind of I guess everybody's
opinion about you only get one because
otherwise we'd be here all night
go ahead so specifically you want a
comment on on Elon Musk's plan to
colonize Mars with SpaceX Sean what do
you feel about colonizing Mars my
understanding was that Elon wanted to
get to Mars himself I don't think he
cares that much about the rest of us
coming along but in a lot because I
think he said he'd rather die on Mars
than live on earth that's what he said I
and I you know I repeat I think it's
it's obviously something that we should
do is to send people to Mars cuz we want
to study it but I don't think we should
consider that any savior for the human
race because again look at Arizona I
mean look at the Sahara it's like we
can't grow trees in the Sahara then
we're not gonna be able to do much on
Mars there you go thank you next
question ed were you from Amos Carla I'm
from an unfasten ating place also called
New York okay yeah and my question is
more on the social side you guys
mentioned about Carl Sagan making a
marketing move as far as taking images
in outer space and all that what do you
think is gonna take for the 21st century
the quote-unquote millennial kind of
generation to get interested in space
and actually propel the next generation
towards space exploration on that
generation now do you think yeah I'm
sorry oh yes so there's a next
generation coming up the Millennials and
those who follow them we had our sort of
pale blue dot and our moon launch and
our forces of Science and Technology to
inspire us do you see anything on the
horizon is that okay
paraphrase of your question yes good
thank you yeah is there anything on the
horizon that you see millions well means
internet cats yes this is what you guys
have created for yourself
Carolyn any reflections now I think the
biggest thing that's going on in the
planetary science community now and also
at NASA is this idea that we're going to
go and find life in the solar system and
so it's gonna take work to do that
because it's actually a pretty hard
question and we got to figure out what
the best way is to do it but it's not
gonna happen I'm gonna be gone but
probably before that great big discovery
happens and they're gonna we're gonna
need young people people who are young
now to kind of you know carry the torch
so people you know and today who were
you as young as you were when you joined
Voyager right so it's it's gonna happen
at some point I mean there's really good
reason to think we actually might find
life in our solar system we just gotta
just gotta you know mount the you know
get going on it all right thank you my
name is Zach from the smellier side of
the River New Jersey
across the moment yes kind of bouncing
off of what you said about life within
our solar system I think everyone here
is in agreement that there's life in the
universe and that's kind of where I'm
going at in the universe as a whole
coming from a you know non-religious man
I am Jewish but you know talking about
it's okay but you know boys
- go on you James but the universe in
general I was wondering what you guys
think you know cuz I know when you put
your head on the pillow at night you
think of what is the universe and what
is the functionality of it is there a
greater cause is it meant for a purposes
of Bill for something I just in three
minutes
I'd love to know what you guys think
simply as fast as you could you know
what you think the universe is okay so
that's so this is free oh my god first
to you I guess is the I I do think that
there has to be life on so many
different parts of the universe and so
that everyone's coexisting but I don't
see why we can't just go to another
planet but I do think it's - like I have
ever all these different species coexist
do you know that you know that we might
be more likely in a matrix than in a
real universe do you ascribe to that
philosophy I I remain convinced that if
we figure out a way to make a perfect
computer simulation of a world or of a
universe and in that simulation there is
what we would call life and that life
has free will as programmed in that they
could then decide that they want to make
a simulation of a universe themselves
and if each one of these simulations
reaches a point where it makes a
simulation of the universe then most
universes that will exist will be
simulations and if that is the case then
the likelihood that we now are in a
simulation compared with being the first
actual universe that created the life
that made the simulations is very high
so
I heard there are no dragons then I
would be deeply intrigued I'm intrigued
by that possibility that we are the
playthings of a higher intelligence and
every now and then they get bored so
they throw in you know they stir the pot
a little and they say okay Donald Trump
say this today everybody and then
they're watching this and they're
entertained by it all beacon theatres
thank you
[Applause]
this episode of star talk is brought to
you by curiosity stream we are back on
Startalk live in Beacon Theatre
[Applause]
search for aliens is that a good thing
maybe maybe not and what impact would
that should that have on our culture on
our civilization and we've got a panel
of fun folks to help us decode these
questions I've got a friend at colleague
Carolyn Porco head of the imaging team
of Cassini mission to Saturn Carolyn
Porco yes
[Applause]
I and I call it madam Saturn and you
okay with that I never asked okay okay
good thank you could be it could be
worse perfect
we've also got Sean Ono Lennon who is an
artist and musician
[Applause]
and Eugene tell us who you brought
Michael Ian Black and Vanessa Bayer all
right so Carolyn some of the images that
you were in charge of bringing back or
or assembling creating because the field
of view of the camera is not so large
that you get everything you have to
mosaic many of the big pictures sweeping
pictures that we've seen the end of the
day we're looking at shadows of the ring
cast on the ball the Sun is here and and
you see the the how many tiny rings make
up the big ring and I'm looking at say I
want this as a poster on my wall and so
Sean do you see the space pictures as
arc
I certainly do in fact um even when I
was very young I actually gave Carolyn
this painting because we became friends
recently and I painted Saturn and I
remember realizing later on that the
coloring of Saturn was artificially
colored and I was so depressed I was
like well what does Saturn really looked
like and and that's what's so cool about
Carolyn's work is that she's actually
showing us more you know beautiful
images of what Saturn really would look
like to our eyes but I was always kind
of surprised that they color them and I
know it's for science and stuff you're
talking about false-color pay you know
it looks so so colorful Saturn but
actually I realized that Carolyn's
pictures are much more accurate today I
follow it for sure so so Carol if you go
back into the early 60s space missions
no one really the scientific community
didn't really want to send cameras
because the pictures are you fine but
there's no real data in a picture you
want you want chakra quarters and and
measure magnetic fields and spectral
distributions and so how do you how did
photography of cosmic objects rise to
such a height well let me this is a very
interesting little tidbit of planetary
science history but in the early days of
the space program
Neil is right they didn't want to send
cameras and it was Carl Sagan who was
arguing
he argued a billion times he argued for
bringing along cameras on planetary
missions when all the other scientists
thought pictures were for PR they
weren't basic science and they would
just be taking up space on a spacecraft
but he lost not only space but weight
weight of a camera l think I need a big
money budget every day so the first I
think I've got this right the first
planetary mission didn't have a camera
but he eventually won the war and we've
had cameras on spacecraft ever since but
you know how did they get that reverse
shot of the moon craft taking off from
the moon I mean you know what I'm
talking about
in 1969 when they actually land on the
moon there's this reverse shot where the
moon lander goes back up off the moment
was her cameraman sitting there like no
there was a camera that was left on the
lunar module that took that was left on
and took up that's a pretty spectacular
shot there was the camera man it was
just sitting there I just was always
amazed that they they got a shot of them
leaving because I mean I think what
ultimately happened NASA is formed as an
agency first to compete with Russia the
Soviet Union and to show our
technological Mike and you're right the
public relations wasn't so much about
what you do with the science it was
about here's our astronauts that the
public relations was all through that
lens and so later on you would learn
that when you take those kinds of
pictures people eat it up and it
transports them into that moment and
then NASA's budget becomes a little more
stable and and people no matter who they
are have some sensitivity and interest
in continuing this adventure that's
right
and and but it looks that way because
your mission
did you like nothing else ever goes well
thank you I'm glad you noticed but I you
know
I was on I was on the Voyager mission
and believe me the Voyager was just
absolutely the most magnificent romantic
mission you could ever have been on you
were young boundless I was young there
was a time when I was young and I
noticed I mean as great as it was I was
noticing that you know the pictures were
being processed basically to support
press conferences so most of the
pictures that were released to the
public by the Voyager mission were put
out in you know a period of about seven
days around each of the flybys and they
weren't there wasn't a lot of attention
paid to be clear Voyager visited many
planets Judy's not going to orbit around
them so hence the word flyby had very
high currency back then because you
never hung out at the planet that you
visited that sweet flyby Saturn Jupiter
Uranus Neptune and each of those have
this package that's what you do that's
right so and there wasn't a whole lot of
attention paid to how you process the
images or getting the color right and so
when I was made the leader of the
imaging team on Cassini this was like
one of my cardinal goals it's not like I
could tell my fellow scientists this but
I had it in my mind that I was going to
make the pictures absolutely as
beautiful and as natural as I could so
the public would feel like they were
along for the ride so and that's what we
did and I'm you know really the great
[Music]
[Applause]
Michael Vega where are the Voyager
spacecraft now they're about don't call
me on this but something like 16 to 17
or 18 light hours away from here had are
they out of the solar system one of them
Voyager 1 has crossed kind of the edge
of the magnetic bubble so to speak so we
can legitimately say it's an
interstellar space but you can't
legitimately say it's no longer under
the influence of the Sun because it's
got to go really really far is that the
heliopause the edge of the magnetic
field why isn't it called the heliopause
the edge of the magnetic field of this
oh yes yes it is so it went past the
heliopause and they know from the
character of the charged particles and
the rate that they were impacted the
direction they hit it and the direction
and all that that it finally got to the
interstellar medium hit your stove and I
thought that was a I thought that just
sent chills up so and long before it got
there
it passed Neptune the point you gorgeous
you know no I'm sure uh for the pebble
doc oh yeah yeah so Voyager 1 the two
voyagers so Voyager 1 passed Neptune
past the orbit of Neptune orbit of
Neptune the last planet yes solar system
and and you will leave it alone
he's right he's right and they turned
the camera around yes by whose prompting
tell me about that okay so this was just
an idea that I had as soon as I was made
a team member of the Voyager imaging
team which was right after I got my PhD
so this was like in October of 1983 I
went to work for Brad Smith who was the
head of the imaging team you got your
PhD if I remember correctly from Caltech
Caltech in May of 1983 anyway Niki
Eugene for establishing that Caltech is
a good school
somebody's gotta so I just thought it
would be great to take a picture
actually my idea was to take a picture
of the solar system because I knew
Voyager 1 was not going to encounter any
more planets after Saturn and I had a
different idea than Carl who eventually
had also proposed this but I didn't know
about his effort he didn't know about
mine I thought wouldn't it be great to
show what the solar system would look
like to an alien coming in from outside
that's what I wanted to do Carl at a
family photo of a planet yes and Carl
wanted to take a picture of the solar
system too but he really was after that
whole you know romantic idea of showing
the earth as he didn't he hadn't coined
the phrase yet pale blue dot but that
was his idea and to show the picture of
the earth awash in a sea of stars you
know just that emphasize the loneliness
the tiny mess of our planet in the hopes
of engendering feelings of planetary
brotherhood and so on so I I was going
around Hawking it on the Voyager project
in like 1984 Annie tells me his wife
tells me he had started two years
earlier and Riaan we both got like dull
stares like you want to do what you want
to take a picture of the earth it's only
gonna be a pixel what are you crazy get
out of here
they're kind of that kind of a response
and finally as the mission we're really
getting near the end they slapped you
know
that's just my audio visual effect
so finally Carl then when I say they
didn't want to do it the Voyager project
didn't want to do it then big guys the
ones who made the decisions Carl went to
NASA he went all the way to the NASA
Administrator and convinced the head of
NASA the head of NASA and so the people
at the Jet Propulsion Laboratory were
directed to take this picture and that's
what we did it provides it's so hard
isn't there a lot of downtime I mean you
just find through space can't you just
say it's just turn the camera round for
a second why is that so hard I think it
required doing something that we hadn't
done in the Voyager project and that was
taped of antennae which was continuously
in those days pointing to the earth and
actually break communications take it
off so we could use the antenna to
shield the camera from the Sun or else
you wouldn't be able to take this
picture and then take the antenna and
point it back to the earth and they were
afraid they'd never get it back there so
it wasn't until Voyager 1 was completely
done with its mission its planetary part
of the mission that they let us do this
and they managed to regain
communications anyway but we became the
famous pale blue dot image that became
the the it became almost the spiritual
inspiration for the book Carl Sagan's
book the pale blue dot its iconic I mean
it just really people really loved it
so it's just earth just barely a pixel
in the image and it was not in a sea of
stars but it's a sea of nothingness and
that's just because the aperture of a
lens if you said it for the Lightning
the lighting of the earth and you're not
gonna see the stars but they're there
it's not like they weren't okay of
course there are stars there it was
ready
he's trying to keep us honest keep it
honest right is it your exposure matters
here and you I call out I don't think
there were stars there so alright so in
the pale blue dot the book Carl Sagan
wax poetic and philosophical and with
great elegance on what our place is in
space and in the universe in general
upon reflecting on this pale blue dot
and and but you were not happy with the
pale blue dot where are you you decided
to take another pale blue dot I did so
what did you do so ok so I had always
since the first one had it in well since
I became the leader of the imaging team
I had it in my mind to do that picture
over again only make it better
and well because you know in a proposal
that Carl wrote to the project the
Voyager project to request that they
take this picture he wrote this is not
commonly known but he wrote that the the
idea was to take a picture of the earth
and I quote awash in a sea of stars and
as Neil said that picture didn't win
didn't capture Stars and the earth was
sitting on a beam of scattered light and
of course none of this matters because
Carl you know he was the master of
romancing things and and turning the
whole thing into a you of the allegory
on the human condition so if his nose
was bigger than the image itself right
yes right it just gave him the
opportunity to point out you know our
cosmic circumstance so I wanted to take
the picture that probably Carl would
have wanted and as I was looking through
the timeline of events that my
colleagues were planning and I were
planning for the science that we were
going to collect with Cassini and I
found an opportunity that wouldn't get
anybody too angry and I'm not taking too
much time too much resources to take
this mosaic with the earth in it it
occurred to me wow you know why instead
of doing what everybody seems to have
done since the original pale blue dot
and take the picture of the
and then two weeks later tell everybody
hey while you aren't looking we took
your picture and isn't it beautiful here
it is I thought why don't we tell the
people of the world ahead of time that
on such-and-such a date at such-and-such
a time your picture is going to be taken
and go out as the window of opportunity
opens and look up and think about your
position on this planet and the
neverending blackness of space and how
unique our planet is and it's you Josh
you got to step outside of their house
and look up at Saturn while you took
their picture I did it was the original
Pokemon go
[Applause]
no it was it turned out to be what you
had a cute name for it was it called
it's called the day the earth smiled the
day the Earth's because I asked
everybody to go out and smile you know
smile in celebration of being alive on
the field who thought it was like like
the biggest cosmic performance art ever
so is that part I mean you're you're an
artist kind of yes and but we have a
scientist here talking about beautiful
pictures and and engaging people and and
this is not how scientists usually talk
but is how an artists artists live for
that sure I mean I think you know the
intersection of science and art and math
and art I mean I think a lot of
musicians think of music for instance as
a kind of audio geometry you know I mean
you can easily graph pitch and time and
volume you know on a graph it's
chargeable and and so in a way you know
melody and music could be considered a
kind of audio mathematical language
there's actually this quote that I want
to tell you that I don't know if you've
heard it is kind of a way that was way
deeper than the time it took you to
communicate that sigh that was just I
have to pause on that so music is an
audio geometry well yeah there's this
quote that's relevant to this it's not I
wasn't on a tangent here but yeah you
know this guy James Joseph Sylvester who
was the tutor for Florence Nightingale
who invented nursing or modern nursing
anyway yeah he's a good guy or she's a
amazing woman but he has this quote that
some music is the music is the
mathematics of sense and mathematics is
the music of Reason which i think is
beautiful
[Music]
it was rough going Puff Daddy
is the Jupiter of no I'm kidding anyway
so I do you think that I mean in fact
most of my I notice I mean most of my
mathematically and scientifically minded
friends are in professional scientists
tend to be really big art fans too so
there's definitely an intersection
personality-wise but one of the things I
was thinking about you know leading up
to this show was was music was science
and art actually the same kind of thing
you know in Babylonian Sumerian and
Egyptian times I mean what I mean by
that was was there art for art's sake or
did it always have a function I mean
hieroglyphs were telling stories and
mythologies and you know being an
architect to make a pyramid you know you
were a scientist and astronomy and
astrology were kind of the same thing
because it was all part of religion and
I guess what I'm saying is I think
science and art were by definition
intersected until a period later on when
they started to be totally separate
because I feel like now art what defines
art from science or anything else is
that art doesn't have a function it
doesn't have a purpose other than to be
art so art for art's sake I mean that's
why it's not math or science but but I
feel like you know in da Vinci's time
friends I mean this is more like a
question da Vinci was a scientist and an
artist did he really feel there was a
huge separation between those things I
don't know I based on the notebooks of
his that I've looked at all right it's
all the same exactly I mean he's
sketching horses and studying the
muscular you know patterns and the skin
in fact I think I think we have some
some residue of that time in our modern
some of our modern referencing so for
example today you would say she's got it
down to a science and on the others
you'd say he raised it to an art raise
it to an art form and science and arts
show up in those two phrases and in each
of those cases we kind of mean the same
thing yeah somebody has taken a craft to
an extreme limit of perfection and the
only way you can reference that is to
say they've raised it to an
or got it down to a science I want to
bring this back to what started it
Carolyn did the day the earth smiled and
everyone got engaged in a in an activity
that was symbolic and people were
touched fairy by the science and I've
seen lyrics that you've written and
co-written that were touched by science
and so you're not just an observer of
what's going on
it has infused who and what you are as
an artist and I'm enchanted every time I
learn that such a thing happens you've
got it I got you what you got yeah I
have a sign I was a song here called
nebula boy yeah well I have a band with
my girlfriend called the ghost of a
saber tooth tiger it's a catchy title
and we have a bunch of songs I mean I
mean we're both kind of science groupies
and I say where science Groovy's because
if I were to say I was a science nerd
that would mean I'd actually have to
know facts but as a groupie I'm just
kind of waiting backstage and waiting to
be touched by science as it were
[Applause]
but yeah
I don't mean you specifically Neil but
you know but I'm open to it
what's the title of your album
it's monolith Phobos that's my model
list of Phobos yes one of one of Mars
Mars news well the origin of that record
title which is my the most recent record
I put out with a band called the
delirium is I don't know if you guys
have seen it but there's a there's a
c-span interview with Buzz Aldrin or he
says there's a monolith on Phobos and I
don't know who put it there maybe God
put it there but we have to go boldly
forth and he kind of gets really excited
and I thought it was here's a t-shirt
that says get your ass to Mars exactly
he's really interested but I just
thought it was the most amazing
interview I'd ever seen I mean I assumed
it was gonna be front-page news of every
newspaper but no one seems to have seen
this have you guys seen that okay
because it's pretty unbelievable I mean
it's the second manlet who have landed
on the moon telling us that there's a
structure on Phobos I mean look I know
he's not saying it's artificial you know
about the hexagon on Saturn right
sometimes I can't wait to tell him
okay but the point is you're inspired by
the science that's unfolding around you
yeah we have a song called Schrodinger's
cat which orders to roediger sky exactly
and the strategic Schrodinger was a
physicist yeah under mental - the birth
of quantum physics as a branch of
physics right but didn't he come up with
the Schrodinger's cat scenario to
disprove the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle meaning he was making fun of
it as a test there's a thought
experiment he was against it as my when
he wasn't for I I don't know what it was
for against it but if you're smart it
doesn't matter you challenge people's
others or other people's thoughts right
well I wouldn't know anything about that
what I mean is if you if you're smart in
the room you can pose a question that's
either right or wrong but if it
challenges other people to think more
deeply than they were before that is
useful whether or not it turns out the
way you had intended my holidays
geocentric known universe had earth in
the middle
everything orbiting around it and he
came up with epicycles it was a whole
mathematical model all turned out to be
wrong
[Music]
fascinating it became a fascinating
model to try to attack to see if you can
find out why that was wrong
is there an experiment that could that
could falsify it and so so this is this
is what led to the great insult going to
insult a scientist you say your work is
not right and it's not even wrong some
little bits on that bird so I'm just I'm
looking at your lyrics here
I'm very pressed oh well I mean I'm
embarrassed now to read them but I was
told to so I'm going to give us just
before okay so Schrodinger's cat it's so
dorky isn't it
so yeah we wrote this song in a I guess
there's if there's a few science
references in here well this is
philosophical it says like a tree that
falls alone in the woods without a sound
I can't be sure that I exist when you're
not around
what would you pause when you say
something deep
yes yes that was beautiful it was
becoming your dad again
oh well yeah that's the course of
Schrodinger's cat is like a tree that
falls alone in the woods without a sound
I can't be sure that I exist when you
are not around Neal when physics math
philosophy shows up in an artist's
creative lair so do you think today
there's more or less or what what's the
trend line in The Hunger people have
either for art or for science or for
their marriage going forward and I say
that because for example there are
significant appearances of films where
scientific accuracy was strongly valued
yet it needed an entire room full of
artists to create the visuals for the
stories that we're told and that
included interstellar the movie gravity
especially the movie the Martian right
yeah so I guess what you're saying is
our people more interested in seeing art
represents science accurately than they
used to be in the past no I wasn't being
that pedantic I just say I'm sorry it's
just do you
you are evidence of this are you a trend
line or you an anomaly of artists I
don't really answer yes you the moving
frontier of science to serve just as his
side as an aside Neil I'm also an art
[Applause]
well yeah I was gonna say I don't really
have my finger necessarily on the pulse
of much I mean I have my own pulse but
the universe serving as the artist mu
well that day you know I thought about
this and and I think that what's
interesting is that art until dekho I
think this is true was you was always
looking to nature for its inspiration I
mean if you look at Art Nouveau which
precedes deco everything was flowers and
trees and and and naked ladies and then
then something happens during the Dust
Revolution when everything starts to
look like machinery and it's because we
stopped looking to nature for
inspiration which I would say would be
like looking to physics for inspiration
and we started getting inspired by like
cars and airplanes and guns which is why
actually deca is not my favorite period
it's cool but everything started to look
like an airplane as opposed to like a
tree you know and so I feel like that
was the time in human history when we
stopped really having as much reverence
for for the universe and nature and and
and for our mother earth because we were
no longer paying attention you know you
know most of the architecture in old New
York is Art Deco right I mean that's I
mean not as much as Florida I've seen
some serious
Deco cities there but you know not to
not have enough issues no I don't want
an honest state to just go underwater
you know just just must be not your
getting themselves underwater no I mean
I guess I think that it's it's a
double-edged sword I think as people's
interest in science and their access to
scientific information to the Internet
is increasing there seems to also be
sort of like a reverse backlash where
people are trying to teach creationism
in school do you see what I mean so at
the same time I didn't see your cause
and effect what I mean oh I didn't mean
it's causal I mean it's it's interesting
that there's happening at the same time
so at once we're becoming more science
literate as a society we're also
becoming less sighs don't you think the
movies can be scientifically literate
movie can help my forces that operate on
us in nature
I just think sci-fi films which are
hugely popular and they make hundreds of
millions of dollars yeah they may be our
only hope to ensure that we carry a
scientifically literate community into
the future less the absence of science
literacy lead to our own extinction
Niels may I ask a question about the
intersection what about the reverse
which also seems common in our leading
to science I from what I see in my light
reading of science a lot of science is
inspired by our scientists are inspired
by things they saw as kids like in Star
Trek or Star Wars heard of that book the
science or the physics of Star Trek it's
kind of dorky but you know it's it's
basically what is possible in Star Trek
and what isn't possible is the 50th
anniversary of
I mean in terms of Hollywood or the
media accurately representing science I
mean next generation was pretty far
ahead of its time in terms of trying to
talk about real physics and wormholes
and parallel dimensions and stuff but I
remember there was this controversy
where there was an episode where they
went back in time there were all these
likes Trekkie nerds being like well I
looked at the stars in the sky in the
star system I calculated wouldn't have
been that position of Orion and all that
stuff yeah which I just think is so
funny but I mean I I just find it so
funny to be really uptight about like
well the plasma engine wouldn't have
been this or that way but they have no
problem with the fact that they're like
you know in space talking to Klingon
it's like that doesn't whenever I
release a tachyon pulse it's pretty much
like it is in psycho now I can't suspend
my disbelief Orion would have been
slightly to the left how am I supposed
to get into this so
they have no life I offend the geek
averse in this moment okay so those
debates that unfold unfold where actual
known science has been attempted in the
storytelling which is why they're not
arguing about whether they can have a
conversation in English with Klingons
sure because that's the fantasy side
where they've stepped off the the circle
of science and then they made stuff up
but if you're going to be if you're
gonna say even have a photon torpedo let
it have some resemblance to an actual
photon and an actual torpedo and we're
going to debate that if you're going to
use a phaser that stuns you like it is
it
[Applause]
take a breath if you can have warp drive
what is the warping mechanism so you can
cross the galaxy during the TV
commercial
speaking of which didn't they just make
darn Theory posing at NASA you would
probably know about this an actual
plasma engine which obviously would be
much slower than jet than jet fuel but
that's what runs the the the enterprise
is a plasma engine isn't it I died
lithium principles which I also have so
so this intersection of what artists do
and what scientific Carolyn you you
advised one of the Star Trek movies I
did
which one the first one start right the
first one of the modern era
Star Trek 2009 okay yes so the one where
they're in the near Saturn hiding no yes
that was my idea nice so do you want
this story do a quick quick quick
okay so I met JJ was at Ted we exchanged
you know cards kind of you gave a TED
talk I did and he heard your TED talk
yes and he said I'm that he okay that's
what he said okay
you didn't say right then we you know
went our separate ways nine months long
I have to say this her TED talk somebody
used her audio yeah and choreographed a
little lego woman painted up to look
like her and the lego person moved in
lego ways giving the exact talk that
Carolyn
cutest thing I ever saw like carrot
Porco Lego it she she's the woman who
did this her name is Maya Weinstock she
set up a stage a little Lego stage
identical to the Ted stage it was
magnificent that that is so that is did
she know we could just watch the TED
talk so anyway nine months later I get a
phone call from someone who says JJ
Abrams wants to talk to you and I said
JJ who I don't I didn't watch loss I
didn't really you know anyway long story
short um nobody understood lost anyway
even those who watched it okay so he
invites me to consult on it he was very
generous about he says I feel like I
need to you know include you in on this
I've seen your talk I'm getting all your
emails about Saturn you know come join
us and consult on this so I thought okay
that's great and expecting we're gonna
have like sessions you know in a big
Hollywood office where we're going to be
shooting the breeze and talking about
the planetary scenes or something like
really cool right so he invites me out
there actually I was on a trip anyway
and he says I asked him could I come up
there to ball says Los Angeles and I
wanted to see something being filmed I'd
never seen a movie being filmed before
and I was hoping I was really hoping I'd
see a scene filmed on the bridge right
doesn't every Star Trek fan want to see
the bridge okay what I get out there and
I'm watching poor Chris Pine is that his
name Chris Pine get the crap kicked out
of them in a bar that's the scene yeah
that's pretty good it's a good scene
well I'll just tell you I saw this poor
guy get hit in the face fall on the
floor get picked up punched again fallen
it wasn't real it's but it happened like
25 times he had to go through this Lego
version but what was real about how they
had the enterprise on to that anyone
else
so so we break for lunch very
unglamorous I'm sitting with Abrams I'm
sitting with the head of special effects
and we're just eating these very boring
meals and out of nowhere he says I've
got a problem and he says we've got the
enterprise coming back into the solar
system to save the earth and they got to
figure out where to hide it it's safe so
I'm thinking this is so ridiculous but
he must be trying to test me right he
just wants to see if I could come up
with any good idea so I say the first
thing that comes into my head I said
well why don't you have it come out of
warp drive in the atmosphere of Titan
and then have it rise out of the haze
and you know with the enterprise and the
Rings and Saturn in the background it'll
be a really groovy scene and to my
surgery to my surprise those were
bitching video to my surprise he says oh
my god that's brilliant and that's all
they ever wanted for me
and they fit together
[Applause]
they did it you know and then all this
gets to your point they sent me like the
first draft of it and I pointed out lots
of errors I said well you've got
tightened on an inclined orbit it's not
really on an inclined orbit you've got
the the atmosphere doesn't look quite
right and the guy who does the special
effects Roger guy yet he's saying oh
look don't worry about it and I said you
don't understand people are gonna know
I'm the science advisor on this and
they're gonna plate
I don't know that Titan is not on
inclined orbit you've got to fix it and
he wouldn't do it he just says if
anybody asks you about this just tell
him it was my father so what happens the
movie comes out and there are blogs and
blogs about what the hell did that Porco
woman do and gosh titans not on an
inclined whoever doesn't she know this I
mean it was just pathetic
that is [ __ ] - Daz John you you think
deeply about the state of the world like
oh no that's diabolical I can't and so
you're are you optimistic or pessimistic
about the role of science or art as a
savior to the human race
well this is actually interesting I I
saw a documentary and this is gonna make
sense
[Laughter]
okay on New York before the invention of
cars and they have this problem where
they couldn't take the horse manure out
of the city without bringing in more
horses to bring it up and it was
actually a disaster whereas if you look
at brownstones they're about eight steps
high because they had to built they
started building the buildings with high
steps so you could step over the manure
so it's actually a more so poop about
yeah up to 30 pounds of manure a day and
New York well yeah how many thousands of
horses where they are in New York well
that was their only form of
transportation other than walking right
so it does a bad design right wait so
was it naturally but wait so just you
said something that I had to talk so of
course to move manure out of the city
you need a horse-drawn carriages
carrying the manure and it poopin all
the way and it was a state of equal
so the poop you got the same poop to
take the poop out as the poop words when
you started there was a poop resonance
equilibrium I think is yes the resident
speaker so so I mean I was looking at
this and what's interesting is it was
this the city was in a state of
emergency they didn't know how to how to
solve the problem and then suddenly I
think the Model T came out and then it
was just it wasn't a problem anymore so
I always try to every since I saw that I
thought you know that's a good metaphor
for the unpredictable nature of
technological innovation so I think we
always have to account for that even
though we're looking at our inevitable
demise that maybe some scientists will
come up with something smart that saves
us that we can't predict ok so your
solution is completely bound up in hope
to just basically to just basically hope
that you know you and Carolyn figure in
fairness you're also counting on alien
slavery
yeah but having said that I did just
unfortunately I probably shouldn't have
but I read this book called learning to
die in the Anthropocene which is by this
guy Roy Scranton who who is very smart
he and I learned the word Anthropocene
from him I'm sure you guys knew it
already but it's the human distinguished
epoch so it's the it's it's the time on
the planet that essentially has been
affected by humans it's the epoch
that's the anthro epoch and he basically
says in other words all other periods in
the geologic history of Earth have been
marked by some natural disaster
volcanoes asteroid strikes and right now
if you look at the signature of what's
going on on earth it is primarily that
of human activity and so therefore the
geologists say there's nothing else we
can call this about blaming on humans
and so you get the ant he's actually
exactly so it's the human caused
environmental impact and all that other
stuff mass extinction which we are also
causing and the the whole point of the
book is that he was actually served he
served in Iraq so he said as a soldier
he had to learn to live with inevitable
death that sort of you know behind each
door because a soldier has to learn to
to accept death and he then he also says
you know people like the Dalai Lama they
meditate on their death every day so his
proposition is essentially that the way
the human race should be able to deal
with the fact that we are causing our
own extinction is to just be like a
soldier and just embrace death
essentially thank you for that happy
thought
Vanessa do you do you have confidence
well you know that reminded me a lot
what you were saying of the finality of
dinosaurs I don't know if you've seen do
you remember the show dinosaurs on TGIF
[Applause]
what the piece I added in the finale but
in the finet and the finale the
dinosaurs died anyways what did you what
in reality they died - no no no but
it's fair but it was like a comedy show
and everyone was having a great time
anyway what did you you can laugh about
the dinosaur sign what he yeah he's
preparing himself for death what are you
doing haha yeah what are you worried
about a movie I think that there we
should be able to just like go to
another planet also grow another what
good is that gonna do okay we put trout
there we'll be fine if we mess up earth
he'll stay here and die she's got a new
planet well also like God we know that
all the other things didn't do that like
we're like oh they stayed here and died
what if they went to like but think
about it we can't even we can't even
terraform Arizona I mean how are we
gonna Tara phone Mars you know sean is
very right about this this whole idea
and let's like get with the program here
we're not gonna take seven billion
people and move them to Mars that's not
what going into outer space we only need
like twenty eight hundred of us right
that's all we need
you don't need a minimum amount of
really fertile people excuse me
so you'd read my bio I wonder if either
I wonder if either aliens will come help
us and save us from ourselves or whether
we will invent artificial intelligence
that will then solve the problems that
we measly humans cannot or destroy the
problems the problems the problems you
don't know about problem do you need me
to tell you but no no here's what the
problem is we invent AI and the IAI
judges that we are virus infecting the
earth and we should be destroyed but
that's not a real problem that's like a
that's not a real problem I mean it
would definitely be a problem of it for
everyone but Ron would be like yeah
whatever I did
Carolyn they don't gotta happen that
would be a real problem okay but what do
you get before you get their core let's
like you're a scientist look to dig
deeper okay um let's dig dig I think the
core of all our problems is that there's
too many damn many of us that's why
there's overpopulation too many what
damn many of us wait wait so we just
just just no terraform another planet
and and we just said you're not gonna
transport should we poison foreigners
food yes Neil a hundred years ago and
150 years ago and 200 years ago people
were worried never says mouth I know
about too many people and the people
would outstrip the food supply now we
got the the fact that anybody is
starving in the world today is not
because there isn't enough food we have
more food than has ever been in the
history of the world it's a distribution
political problems so so what are you
worried about there being too many
people why not innovate so that we can
make as many babies as we want it's just
like it feels crowded Neil
well no because the population as it is
and I know what you're saying what
Malthusian ism is then it's kind of dark
but the the we're already just you know
getting rid of lions and tigers and
elephants I mean these species we can't
even coexist with them now yeah and
human-caused environmental changes so
extreme already though it may be
irreversible so if there were twice as
many people there'd be twice as many
mopeds and cars and that's just
dangerous but twice language I mean you
know how much pleasure twice as many
mopeds
yeah is this a title worried about Belt
you know you say that but in places like
you know Malaysia the Philippines China
they're all on mopeds never to worry we
get rid of those well
Lopez I had the word moped in 30 years
all right so this is a real retro show
it's a bitchin mopeds have you seen my
[ __ ] in the church bitchin moped so yes
I mean what are the problems that I
worry about you said I think deeply I
mean certainly environmental disaster
that's human caused by the Anthropocene
and I wonder also you know Elon Musk and
very intelligent people it's not just a
joke Carolyn they warned against super
malevolent AI wall maybe not malevolent
from its perspective but from our
perspective certainly if it decided as
you said that we were somehow expendable
or some kind of virus to be rid of I
mean have you heard of Rocco's basilisk
Rocco's basilisk someone that person did
is that is that that thing in all of
Garden words all you it's a thought
experiment thinking that if once AI
creates itself then as Chris Val States
it'll be able to infinitely improve
itself in in a sort of blink of an eye
it'll it'll teach itself how to be them
you know the most intelligent thing at
least in the solar system and at that
point it will be essentially a kind of
God because it will you know be almost
omniscient it evolves to be the most
intelligent thing imaginable
then it's morality could be based on
that which helped bring me about is good
and that which didn't help bring me
about is bad because if it had a
morality it would consider itself to be
the most important thing ever and so
that all decisions that led towards it
are good and all decisions that were not
leading towards it would be bad so the
people who are scared of Rochas basilisk
which is the name of the AI are scared
that it would figure out how to
reproduce people through the DNA codons
of from the past in you know doctors
archives or whatever and recreate you
and torture you for eternity in some
kind of weird virtual hell too
for not bringing it about I think the
people who write smoking I was just
using the magic eyes thing we're like a
little scared of some science nobody you
laugh there are people that take it very
seriously in fact if you go on the
website that the idea was first proposed
it's now banned to speak about because
no one wants to mention rocio's basilisk
in online because it'll trace back to
the person who posted it and torture
them I will delete the file tonight I
love the best
oh wait for it what I want to do is give
the last word to Carl Sagan and if we
can dip do you have like a spot or
something just to oh nice okay so you
can take out the rest can you take out
the rest turn the others off turn the
house lights off yeah the housewife's
thank you do you need a little jazz will
end this evening with a reading from the
book of Carl
if you look at earth from space you see
a dot that's here that's home that's us
on it everyone you ever heard of every
human being who ever lived out their
lives the aggregate of all our joys and
sufferings thousands of confident
religions ideologies and economic
doctrines every hunter and forager every
hero and coward every creator and
destroyer of civilization every King and
peasant every young couple in love every
hopeful child every mother and father
every inventor and Explorer every
teacher of morals every corrupt
politician every superstar every Supreme
Leader every saint and sinner in the
history of our species lived there on a
mote of dust earth is a very small stage
in a vast cosmic arena think of the
rivers of blood spilled by all those
generals and emperors so that in glory
and triumph they could become the
momentary masters of a fraction of a dot
think of the endless cruelties visited
by the inhabitants of one corner of the
dot on scarcely distinguishable
inhabitants of some other corner of the
dye how frequent their misunderstandings
how eager they are to kill one another
how fervent their hatreds
our posturings our imagined
self-importance the delusion that we
have some privileged position in the
universe are challenged by this point of
pale light our planet is a lonely speck
in the great enveloping cosmic dark in
our obscurity in all this vastness there
is no hint that help will come from
elsewhere to save us from ourselves
it's up to us it's been said that
astronomy is a humbling and I might add
character building experience to my mind
there is perhaps no better demonstration
of the folly of human conceits than this
distant image of our tiny world to me it
underscores our responsibility to deal
more kindly and compassionately with one
another and to preserve and cherish that
pale blue dot the only home we've ever
known Beacon Theatre thank you
this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service made for those of you
who have no shame in your nerd game with
over 2500 DQ memories and nonfiction
titles from some of the world's best
filmmakers including exclusive originals
get unlimited access starting at just
$2.99 a month and for our audience the
first 31 days are completely free if you
sign up at curiosity stream comm slash
Startalk and use promo code Startalk get
curious with shows on everything from
dark matter to dogs to dinosaurs
curiosity stream is the world's first
streaming service addressing our
lifelong quest to learn explore and
understand original content featuring
Stephen Hawking Sigourney Weaver Michio
Kaku David Attenborough Sylvia Earle
Jane Goodall and many many more
available in many platforms web app Roku
Android Xbox one Smart TVs iOS
chromecast Amazon fire Amazon Kindle and
Apple TV make sure you check out Stephen
Hawking's favorite places renowned
physicist Stephen Hawking takes a flight
of epic proportions to visit his
favorite places in the universe a three
part curiosity stream original series
and an Emmy winner go to curiosity
stream comm slash star talk for
unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and nonfiction series and
for our listeners and a promo code
Startalk when prompted during the signup
process and your membership is
completely free for the first 31 days
you